hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast reference architectures for
like hydrogen bio medical genomics
solution I'm Julia and tired of levers
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we have a few more in
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentations and go we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the side window by clicking
on the screen icon on the lower right
hand corner of the side window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems with green Q&A button at
the lower left today's webinar is being
sponsored by cajon please get more
information at Qi aage 10.com and it is
also being sponsored by intel int dl com
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker Michaelmas antennas and retail
sons work dr. McManus has 30 year
history and scientific software and
hardware marketing roles ranging from
iron bees to sales including business
development marketing project management
and executive management he currently
acts as a senior health and life science
solutions architect at Intel his part of
Intel's effort to promote the use of
modern computational solutions in
healthcare and life science markets
Michael friends bar gives the director
and solutions leave for kind in
bioinformatics high-volume sequencing
solutions in our host Ben mark he has
served over 30 years of combined
experience in the software industry with
specialties in bioinformatics software
architecture service to developer kit
mr. frundsberg has been instrumental in
building strategic alliances and
research collaborations for hydrogen
bioinformatics LML turns over dr.
Michael McManus and dr. McDowell son's
work for their presentation thank you
so welcome everybody and welcome to
today's webinar on reference
architectures for the keg & biomedical
genomic solution in collaboration with
Intel we are very excited about that
because we always get questions for 4
from customers about they have a
specific need a specific sequencing
throughput and what kind of hardware
architecture do they actually need to be
able to analyze this fruit boot so I'm
as as introduced my French Park have
been originally I was part of CSE bio
that was acquired by Kagan three years
ago and I've been with CC bio since
early days so I actually have a 11 years
of experience in this field as mentioned
I'm we are now in chi and bioinformatics
and to give a little overview about what
that is we have we have this information
here and it's actually a formation of
three companies namely as i mentioned
coz x over that i am from and ingenuity
systems and and bio base and together we
are actually the the biggest
bioinformatics company in the world and
we have hundred twenty thousand one
hundred twenty thousand users worldwide
and the 40 of the top 40 pharma
companies rely on our balance on IT
solutions we also have 30 more than
30,000 publications reference in chi and
bioinformatics and and more than 420,000
some sequence samples uploaded into a
more secure and private ingenuity cloud
to give a little introduction to what we
are going to talk about today i would
like to mention that our tagline in
Kagan is from sample to inside meaning
that we we have a unique technology for
every every step in you can say the
universal NGS workflow from sample to
inside all the way from sample its
relation to actually the action election
elbow inside that that you would need
and what we are going to focus on today
here is the what we call the secondary
analysis which is analyzing the data
loaded of the sequencing instruments
that is a the most compute intensive
part of the workflow and thus also the
the part of the work fruit that requires
most compute resources so that's that's
where is actually a relevant to talk
about what kind of compute
infrastructure do you actually need to
be able to accomplish this also I would
like to give a little overview of what
we actually talked about here a software
solution that we provide from from
tagged and bioinformatics it consists of
primarily two products and the primary
product that many that is a very
widespread in the market is called coz
workbench and in terms of CLC genomics
weapons and CSE biomedical workbench and
that is a desktop computer computer
software that you install it on your
laptop or your desktop computer and and
and is and then you are able to analyze
data coming from from the sequencer and
it is a well-known in a market to be
extremely user friendly with a a
graphical user interface that the
computational biologists like and
biologists like a
and also by medical experts is very easy
to use and and this drag and drop and
it's windows and it's in general a nice
user experience to use and then on the
other hand we have the challenge of
analyzing this large amounts of data and
if we are talking a data of a certain
capacity then a desktop computer is not
anymore is sufficient for doing this
analysis even though you technically
could do it with with the interface so
that's why you you bring high
performance computing into the picture
and here we are talking computer
clusters and server-side architectures
that resides in the typically in the
cooling room maybe in the basement or
another room and our sometimes even on
another site and that is a in general a
very complicated area that requires that
traditionally requires a lot of a
computing scale and lot of ite expertise
and in general for scientists medical
expert is very difficult to understand
and it certainly is very difficult to
handle so that's why we have had success
with masking the complexity of a cluster
computing by adding the GOC genomic
server software which you can install on
your cluster architecture and or your
server architecture and the good thing
about this is that scene from from the
end-user perspective that the user
friendly end-user perspective that the
science is like this absolutely no
difference in working with the data and
accomplishing what you actually want to
accomplish so so it's a it's a matter of
instead of executing a task analysis
task directly on your desktop then with
the with the user friendly user
interface you simply submit the task to
the computer trust our environment where
bias then scheduled for execution and
and this Gator gotta get a notification
when the job is done I would come back
to that in a little bit so to be a
little technical we we have to be that
here to explain what it's all about we
have a this small diagram of how it
actually works so how it works is that
when you schedule a work flow through
the workbench to a compute cluster then
it's scheduled for what is called
distributed resource management and that
means that there is a central scheduling
mechanism where you can wait that takes
the whole whole workflow and and put it
into the mechanism and then it is
distributed to the computer resource and
what I mean by a computer resource is
that a compute cluster is typically an
array of what we call compute nodes
which is individual computers and from
from a scheduling point of view then
it's a matter of finding an available
resource in that compute cluster and
then taking the components in the
workflow and schedule into execution on
each of these available notes and if all
notes are busy into doing tasks then
it's put in a queue for later execution
so that means that scene from an end to
the point of view is just a matter of
submitting the workflow to the to the
scheduling mechanism and then they know
that it will be executed eventually when
he say when it reaches point in the
queue there's two ways to schedule that
I'll not come into detail with here and
now and that is called job no sand and
grit no scheduling and there are some
some differences primarily regarding
using external quit scheduling systems I
would like to explain a little bit about
how an organization actually uses this
and as you see up in the top we have the
end users that use the workbench and and
that's the user user experience that
they like and that's what they can do
remember that is very often induces a
scientist biological scientists about
medical experts do not have have the
deep mature IT skills that can make them
handle a command-line tools little
stools on the compute cluster so that's
what they what they can use and then in
the middle we have the this the COC
server the genomic server that that they
then submit the ops 2 and we of course
we also have an IT administrator into
the picture that make sure that the
system is running etc and then on the
other side we have the computational
biologists also and they're typically
called Byron from tissues and and and
very often Lee and actually also
historically the band competitions has
has been the stuff that you can say
owned the resource the analysis resource
so so they have been historically and
also many places still they are serving
as as user interface to watch the end
users in terms of of operating the
analysis engine and that has
historically and we have here are very
often storage from organizations that
there is a conflict between the end
users and the parent for musicians for
that simple reason that the parents
musicians is a very limited resource and
and that when they serve as the user
interface towards the analysis system
then they become even more a bottleneck
because the end users come all the time
with requests for doing different kinds
of analysis that could be blast mapping
or variant calling etc and they end up
spending all that time on serving the
end users and instead of actually doing
behind for medics so and seen from the
end you
point of view that is that can create
some conflicts because they're the this
limited resource that never has time and
is always busy and seen from the band
from pragmatics point of view it can be
the buttering end-users that comes with
stupid questions and cubed requests all
the time and thereby there is a built-in
conflict so that's what we have had
success with in Carrig and plant for my
texts actually resolving this conflict
and make everybody good friends so so
with that with our customization
abilities on the system command line
tools first of all I would like to
mention which gives the same abilities
towards the system in terms of
scheduling and and administration data
administration as from an endpoint
induce a point of view but with a
command-line tool in as interface and
even more importantly i will also like
to mention that we have external
applications integrations and also
sitting on that side so that means that
scene from a parent for magicians point
of view you can deploy other tools and
external tools that could be from many
of the good tools from the open source
environment that could also be tools
that they have developed themselves they
can be deployed into the system and by
specifying in the system how the
parameters work it is then translated
automatically into a user interface that
the ink user can actually use and submit
jobs with themselves so that means that
that it's it will be easier to plan your
day as a bioinformatician because you
can actually choose to liberally when
you want to be available for the end
users and you do not have to be bothered
every time an end user come and ask for
requests for analysis I would also like
to mention as part of the system we have
a data management layer which means that
the data is of course on the server side
starts centrally and available to all
end users and also to bioinformatics
tough and there is his traditional
permissions and access privileges and
mechanisms
around that in terms of who can breed
and look at ride and and who can view
the data and these data normally stored
in a file system but can also be stored
in in the database now I would like to
move on to talking a little bit about
the optimizations we have done for the
intel chipset and also together with the
intel so we are very well known not only
for doing very user-friendly software we
also do well known for doing a very high
performance software and the various
optimizations behind it that i would
like to mention one is that we are using
an intel technology called simdi it
stands for a single instruction multiple
data which actually means that not only
is the software of course you can say
multi-threaded to run on unavailable
course on a computer computer processor
but using this technology is actually
also makes it possible to to run a
single instruction on multiple data so
that if you regard this as multiple data
that could be a vector of 16 numbers
then these 16 numbers can be processed
in a single instruction on the single
core at the time so that's one example
of how we have how we have optimized and
this is a dude this has been done in
some of our most of its essential and
most compute-intensive tools and is
implemented in machine code I would also
like to mention recently we have done a
various enterprise level optimizations
together with until so in the in the
fall we published a white paper around
that we took focus on the absolute
highest throughput that is known which
is comes from the alumina high cg x 10
which is up to 18,000 whole genomes per
year and we have
we have tested we tested this with with
the the throughput that is needed at
highest capacity and we we set ourselves
the challenge of trying to analyze the
data at that speed that is can actually
be produced and we showed with a system
that is described with this point my
paper that own not only can we do this
with system on earth to compute nodes
but also that the system is extremely
scalable linear scalable that is
actually scales up linearly to the to
the data demand to be analyzed so what
we specifically tested is that we had
the tested up simulating a high soup hi
seek extend throughput which is 18,000
whole genomes per year and with that we
we had to solve that with that given
workflow a variant calling workflow we
had 32 compute nodes running in parallel
and with this setup it was possible to
to analyze one whole human genome every
30 minutes in average which means a 48
whole genomes per day and we also made
some tests on whole exomes which added
up to with the same setup of 32 notes to
1440 whole exomes per day and as you
know some of you might know that the
sequence cost on on this is the famous
thousand dollars and and we calculated
with a cost analysis that includes
everything on the computer has power
consumption and space and cooling and
everything we calculated that it could
be accomplished their analysis itself
for $22 per whole human genome
the final thing I would also like to
mention that of course now speed is not
everything that we also have proven
equity and we actually have a page on
that which is given here in the bottom
CAG and I informatics calm / accuracy
that it's not only a high-performance
and extremely user friendly solution but
it's also a highly accurate solution so
a coward comparison of results from the
bio medical genomics over variant
calling workflow together with the IBA
we compared with the gold standards
variance from genome in a bottle use and
did the GSE JS g CAG portal and the
sensitivity and specificity busy visethi
were comparable with ninety seven
percent and up to almost hundred percent
respectively and we also had comparison
to open for pipeline with bwa and same
tools and the variant calling pipeline
had a more than four times lower false
positive rate we see this was very close
to zero and compared to 0.02 23% and we
also have made the benchmarks equity
benchmarks on copy number variation
detection and come up with some really
promising accuracy numbers so by that I
would like to move on to to to my goal
McManus from Intel who is going to
present some of these interesting
reference architectures that we that we
propose for different scenarios thank
you Michael I will switch slides here
let's see so unlike a McManus i work at
Intel and I've been in the industry a
while as well just like the other
Michaels so what I'm going to talk to
you today about is really about some of
the systems and principles behind
building those systems so basically I
wanted to start with a single slide
review of the work that intel has done
in life sciences code optimization so as
you could save your work with kyochon
from michael's discussion but we've
worked with the road we've
worked with many of the life sciences
codes dozens and dozens and genomics and
also in molecular dynamics and
cryo-electron microscopy and
computational chemistry so intel has
made a point to work with these of
vendors of software to make sure that
the software is fully taking advantage
of intel cpus so along with that effort
of optimizing code intel has been
promoting the scalable system framework
which is a concept for building highly
performant in scalable systems and so
basically this is addressing of
bottlenecks better in the industry or in
the computing infrastructure in the
industry so you have you know walls it
exists between memory and storage and
and you have as i mentioned earlier or
not to my software there's a lot of
these effects and then you have a bunch
of different workloads that range from
high performance computing workloads and
infrastructures to Big Data machine
learning visualization a lot of these
systems are not identical and what
scalable system framework is trying to
do is show that you can build a single
system that can encompass all of these
different kinds of workloads and of
course where we as a company are trying
to democratize this we're trying to make
HBC cover these workloads and be
available to everyone so that's a lot of
the effort that's behind this scalable
system framework and if you think about
what we're doing I'm not sure how many
out there seeing some of these slides
but if you have look at today you have
on the left column you have the
traditional structure of you know
compute with its cache you get memory
storage and you've got some sort of
parallel file system like luster but in
the future what we're moving towards is
much tighter integration so you're
getting a high bandwidth memory you're
getting faster much much
Master ssds that are close to memory
speed that are next to the CPU you've
got much faster SSDs for normal storage
and then you're going to basically a
version of things like luster that have
a two tier level two tiers to them one
is a burst buffer which is a very high
speed version of luster but small
capacity and then underneath that a much
larger capacity version that's using
spinning hard drives so this tighter
integration along with optimized
software and this whole idea of how to
build scalable systems is what's
enabling more performance to come out of
part of the systems that are being
designed so a standard system that you
might want to think about it is
basically shown here on this slide so
somewhat obvious but you have compute
nodes and you have the i/o nodes and
what I was just speaking about like a
first buffer kind of node you have your
fabric whatever that could be could be
on the path from Intel could be infinite
and it could be Ethernet even then you
have nodes for logging in and managing
the whatever the size of the system you
may not need that for a small system and
then the parallel file system which is
typically luster and then some ways to
get data into and out of the system
which is typically either InfiniBand or
10 or 40 gig Ethernet so that and then
just also some software that goes that
you could use in larger installations
which some costs already software that
Intel provides its source so so let's
just talk about sizing and for a second
some of the parameters here so if you
take a look at a general schematic this
is just a rough schematic but you'll see
that you've got on the right you've got
compute nodes you've got fabric you've
got management which is one gigabit
ethernet and again the fabric can be
faster ethernet it can be InfiniBand it
can be on the path
and then you have storage and the login
and gateway loads so those are the basic
components this is just an easier to
absorb schematic so that's the idea and
if we continue on here we'll see that so
those of you who maybe don't know me I'm
a chemist an organic chemist by by
training but after doing a lot of these
benchmarks it came to me that we can
consider you know a standard workload we
are running a number of genomes as a
like a chemical reaction you could
derive a rate constant that is
characteristic of that particular
workflow just as a use in estimating
systems it's obviously not going to be
super precise but it is good way to
estimate how to scale your system so you
can run a genome workload the next own
workload gene panel workload or in RNA
seek workload and you can come up with
constants that will help you understand
how to build your system and you can use
what I've been doing is expressing these
constants as how many for example
genomes per node per unit time and so
I'll go into that in a minute but
basically this is the idea you just you
have in this case from vascular VCF you
have an overall workflow that you can
define these constants for so there's
also a storage constant so that you can
consider which is like how much on a per
node basis storage do I need as you're
building your system so I've some
assumptions here that are just based on
storing all the files for now obviously
the customer can do what they want and a
little bit of extra buffer to make sure
there's room but these are these are
sort of worst-case scenarios just to
make sure the scale is right so
basically what you have are 430ex genome
you can read the numbers but they're not
in significant numbers I mean 600 gigs
and much larger 450x genomes and these
are the numbers that are you
used in some of the storage calculations
so long so these K values you know
really where do they come from as I
mentioned they come from actually
running benchmarks so basically we
Michael alluded to this we ran 30 30 X
whole genomes we're in 24 whole genomes
and 24 hours on a 16 node cluster this
is where the Intel 2697 b3 this is a has
world class a processor it was using
luster and you come up with a with this
rate constant of one and a half genomes
per node per day or 45 genomes per node
per month and just keep all the review
these in a bit you can do the same thing
for exomes which is in the white paper
that Michael described earlier and you
come up with a ko'd 45 exomes per node
per day or thirteen hundred and fifty
per month and you can see the difference
in scale between genomes and excellence
in terms of how many you can do and then
internal benchmarks that Michael at
kyochon has team has done was to run
some gene panels on a slower processor
still I Haswell processor but a slower
one and there the K for those benchmarks
is per panel since they're smalls 175
panels per node per day or or five
thousand or so from per node per month
and then finally RNA seek runs and these
numbers are much smaller per node
because they take a lot longer to run so
you can see the numbers are not so not
so large so the next the next slide then
shows some of the storage numbers also
from some benchmarks and so basically if
you use the numbers that I shown on the
slide about for like 600 gigs as the max
say 430ex genome for a fast queue and
all the other files you end up with a
thought of 27 terabyte per node per
month and you just keep repeating this
but I will point out that if you look at
the exone number here you see that
exomes accumulates storage far faster
than genomes because you can process
them much quicker than the ratio of the
file sizes so they accumulate very
quickly and then of course gene panels
go pretty quickly and it's fairly
similar if you're processing a full
pipeline to be similar to the
consumption source consumption of
genomes and then finally RNA seek which
are slower and take as a result take
less storage per month so if I were to
just summarize these you can just see
them here on a promo basis so I just
want to talk a second about luster
because you know what is the role of
luster and you'll see on the right under
storage type the iee L is actually intel
enterprise edition for luster and nasa's
network attached storage and um so
Westar gives you tremendous scalability
and expandability and as I mentioned you
can use in larger systems a two-tier
system of SSDs for a burst buffer and
spinning drives for capacity tier
however if you're just building a small
system and you're going to remain small
me don't necessarily need to scale you
can consider using SSDs instead of using
lustre just depends on your on your
needs and not just to be clear SSDs are
used in the burst buffer to it's just in
a different way then and then in a small
system and just to show you this is a
this graph came from a white paper that
HPE relief released recently and it
shows an alignment process using bwa and
it shows some using network attached
storage and the blue line and it shows
luster in the orange line and as you add
nodes you can see muster is relatively
flat whereas the network attached
storage has trouble keeping up as you
add notes so just a something to keep in
mind this shows how must remix things
fairly
stable and performance so let's talk
about sequencers for sex so we talked
about all these constants and now the
challenge is you got a sequencer it's
got a bunch of output and now you know
per node how many genomes you can do how
much stored is going to take so we have
to do kind of an impedance match here
and try to figure out and I'll pick a
few examples of how to line up a set of
nodes with a specific sequencer so um
care of all the sequencers that I shown
on the prior slide and this is a table
that comes from their documents which
shows their performance on a monthly
basis and so what I did is I said okay
here's all these note of these on
monthly outputs and I use the K values
and just made the table so that show the
number of compute nodes needed to match
that monthly throughput and you'll see
that the 32 nodes some under the high cg
x 10 on the left is what Michael was
talking about and then all the other
nodes I'll explain as I go along and
then for storage combine the same grid
up you can see the storage on the
monthly basis some for each of the nodes
that you need for to match the output of
the sequencers so what we do is we take
this information when we take an example
like a gene panel example and let's just
look at the thermo fisher I in PGM so it
does 840 panels a month and using those
prior numbers it really only takes one
compute node and we'll need 26 terabytes
of storage for that particular 30 days
and you can do that with one as a scene
here one node and if you use lustre then
you have from the metadata server you
have the object storage server and then
your actual storage targets which is
part of the lustre configuration and you
can actually add this is capable of
doing 5,000 panels a month
so you can run several PGMs off of this
so you can add more nodes for compute
but you would have to add more notes for
storage to make sure you can accommodate
all the panel storage but it's a
scalable system now if you go to say an
alumina hi seek one of the things that
Intel recommends is you use this for
node configuration that's in a 2u rack
space and really dense nodes and they
work really well they're available from
a variety of manufacturers so alumina
does hi-c 2500 is 900 x owns a month but
the k value for this is 1350 exomes a
month for just one node so you could
actually put this for node system in and
just populate one node and then as you
need to expand you can populate the
other three nodes and add more storage
so your investment that you've made and
your your architecture here can can be
preserved so that's 135 terabytes of
storage you need and this this were to
accommodate um you know if you added
another node to this so that you had to
the four nodes occupied you could
satisfy roughly three high seat 25
hundreds of sway doing exomes let's see
so if we continue on for RNA see the RNA
seek runs are more compute intensive and
these are using this slower chip in that
benchmark but it needs about 11 nodes
and so you would use three of these four
node systems so you have 12 notes but
you don't need as much storage so you
can dial back the storage if you're
doing just RNA seek for example and then
finally watching up finally if you have
an alumina high seek x10 this is the 32
node configuration roughly that that
Michael talked about and you have eight
of these four node servers you have
fabric you have
um your login node your gateway node and
your luster set up which is if I can
annotate here you know this is all
luster these are your compute nodes here
so and then also part of luster is the
you know these these areas here so
anyways this can be scaled and if you
want to scale all this you can try to
add a second x 10 and if you do that you
would go from say the 32 notes to 72
notes and then you could handle
basically three thousand genomes a month
actually can handle bit more than that
but in general that's that's 64 notes we
keep you up with two high seek x 10's
but you'd have a little growth if you
were to go to this kind of configuration
no these i'll talk about these systems
more specifically in a minute but
basically you know these are generic
systems right i'm not specifying the OEM
in other words the hardware vendor i'm
not being specific about you know what
the actual storage configuration is
because it would take way too much time
in this in this webinar to to cover all
of those details but what i want people
to take away from this is that if you
think about your problem in terms of how
many genomes or exomes or whatever
entity you're running on a per day or
per month basis you can with the right
cpus you can actually determine very
quickly how many as an estimate how many
nodes and how much storage you need to
be able to process your workload and
that and that hopefully
so those questions so in closing and
hopefully people can see this the so as
I mentioned the details of this we've
done with the Haswell processor now of
course everyone may know maybe you don't
that the broadwell processor is out and
we haven't repeated these benchmarks yet
with the broadwell cpus so rather than
provide detailed estimates I can just
tell you that what in like what Intel
it's published is that they see a
performance increase between 27 and
forty-four percent but of course that's
in general we would have to redo these
benchmarks for the specific kaijin
workflows to UM to actually see this and
so so the system's designs here as I
said our generic if people have an
interest like if you have a particular
vendor you work with and you want to
build a system intelligent can work
together to assist you in getting
something that's design that's specific
to that hardware vendor and with that I
think I'd like to hand it back to
Michael flensburg to wrap up
hi actually I can take it from here this
is julia child again I'm the moderator
and I want to thank you for that
informative presentation so before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience on how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them into
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation we go oh
there's one more slide okay please shoot
that one more side and then I'll
continue just second I need to find the
side I would just like to round off with
a little information of links our email
addresses for Michael and me where you
can find us and in the email universe
and also mention a few resources that we
have available so first of all we have
the white paper around the the total
cost of ownership benchmark that we made
for hi CJ external data analysis and
then I would also like to mention here
that we have in this regard we have a
blog post that is also posted with a URL
here and now we're also most importantly
like to mention that that for this
solution and the work we have been doing
here around optimized code there is a
page on the insole domain and then I
would would also like to mention that we
have a of course a solution page for
biomedical genomic server I just given
at the bottom of this page and thank you
for listening hi everyone again sorry
about that and so as I was saying we
just like to remind you on how to submit
questions and you can submit them by
just typing them into the Q&A box which
can be found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we will try to
answer as many questions as we can so
our first question is there an api and
sdk hub will be available for the CLC
server and if so how about the
documentation for this
so I think that is question for me this
is michael from from kaigan so yes we
have a very comprehensive API and sdk
for for the solution and we have a whole
portal around it called CLC developer
connection that if you google that then
you can find it whereas I contains a
free SDK and also and it's free to sign
up in general and also all the
documentation that is needed here both
in terms of descriptive information but
also in terms of examples and also we
have a discussion forum that is actually
quite active where it is developers
those are using our developer tools can
exchange information and questions ok
the next question what is the practical
difference between Java notes scheduling
and grid notes literally so I think
that's also a question for me so so this
job now scheduling is a is a relatively
simple job no is scheduling mechanism
that is built into the system it does
require a dedicated compute cluster for
our solution and that is the the biggest
difference to grid scheduling which is
typically larger clusters that are
shared between different applications
and usages induces a one of these third
party vendor schedule us that could be
pppps pro sound good engine open close
engine Oracle grill engine etc they do
not require a dedicated compute cluster
since they shared between applications
so that's as I see it the primary
differences between those two scheduling
mechanisms X question does the TCL
calculation includes server
administration costs nowhere that's
actually the only thing that is not
included and that is for the simple
reason that is almost impossible to
casual
it giving any estimates in general
because the salary level is very
different different from country to
country and regional tilcox geographies
and also that it is a there's a huge
difference on from computer system to
computers to know how much i see effort
and administration effort it contain so
that's actually the only thing that is
not included because i have a mix of
sample types how do i make sure i buy
the most appropriate hardware that's
probably for me michael mcmahon is here
it's a good question as most people
don't just run one different one type of
sample they want to mix and so now if
you know that exomes are the most
storage consumptive and you know genomes
of the most compute-intensive you can
design your system to have enough nodes
for compute and to have enough storage
for exomes and and so it just takes a
little thinking but you can build
systems that will encompass the
processing of genomes and storage of
exons so you know you have enough
general storage for all of the different
sample types that you need how different
is the hardware from each vendor and
those that was a challenge for a
building assistant oh okay I'll take
that one oh yeah well it's a good it's a
good question on the hardware there
there are some common threads for
example that if you saw the at the
beginning the to you for node server
pretty much all of the hardware vendors
have that compute server that dense you
know for nodes in a to you space so that
is a one of the reasons I chose it is
only for its density but also because
it's commonly available across a variety
of hardware vendors the storage parts a
little trickier because the vendors have
quite a variety of
George configuration so if you're
building although the if you w lustre
solution although the high level
components are the same you know you
have an object storage server you have
storage targets you have metadata
servers and things like that those that
those pieces of common to lustre but the
notes they run on our do vary so that
creates a little bit of a challenge but
I it's certainly clear to us now how we
would do this across a different variety
of vendors so intelligent can help if
you have questions how much energy does
it take to sequence a genome informatics
ah oh well I have looked at that uh
basically it's roughly about if you do
the entire process for a whole genome
and roughly a 50x whole genome it's
about 15 and a half kilowatt hours to do
a genome and and that of course is going
to depend on the CPU and the specific
kind of hardware you're using on outside
of the CPU and put a type of storage and
right if you have hard disks that are 11
lots of peace for example vs SSD so it
does make a difference but using as soon
as a general number 15 and a half
kilowatt hours or about 55 mega joules
for those people that don't like
kilowatts but so it's basically you know
300 watt light bulbs for 24 hours to do
the sequencing which is about seven
kilowatt hours and the informatics is a
little more it's at 8.2 kilowatt hours
and what's about um 300 watt light bulbs
and a 40 watt light bulb for 24 hours
just to give you some sort of from sense
and then the interpretation piece which
is after you have been DCF is small it's
um it's only you know a quarter of a
kilowatt hour which is 10 watt light
bulb for 24 hours just to give people of
this
and so you know it adds up if you do a
lot of genomes in some countries you
know our energy consumption is an
important issue and so it's it's a good
question okay so if there are normal
questions I would like to once again
thank dr. McManus and dr. Sommer for
their presentation do you have any final
comments but i am just want to thank
everyone and if there is interest out
there and constructing systems for
genomics that if you're interested in
the cottage and pipeline you should
start where michael and i will assist in
behind the scenes if need be in terms of
any kind of hardware discussion but
thank you all yeah thank you ok so
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari
second you will receive an email from
Lavery's alerting you in this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to throw it that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time and
goodbye